in today's eye on money Macy's America's
largest department store company is
trying to end a years-long slump
by closing 125 low-performing stores and
slashing corporate jobs the company
announced yesterday that it will close
about a fifth of its locations over the
next three years Macy's will also cut
around 2000 jobs at its offices in
Cincinnati and San Francisco it's
unclear how many retail workers will be
affected by the store closures CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
Hill Jill Jill good morning I was
looking at a graph last night and it's
peak Macy's had 800 something stores yes
and now going down to 400 and this is a
company like many other big department
store chains that's been suffering from
dual challenges first from some of the
big boxes like a Walmart or a TJ Maxx or
a target some of whom have been much
better in pricing and then the advent of
online shopping and Amazon and it's
really startling to look at one
particular graph that I saw also which
is the stock price of Macy's over the
last five years versus the stock price
of Amazon Macy's down by 74% over the
last five years
Amazon up by four hundred and thirty
seven percent I mean that is pretty
startling he sees Jill do you can they
stay in business will they stay in
business well I think this is gonna be
an interesting pivot because the CEO
came on board a few years ago is really
focusing on what are our best performing
stores let's close these massive stores
some of which are in malls where people
aren't going anymore
focus on the high performing stores but
they're adding a couple of things
they've got a lower end brand that
they're bringing on and actually opening
new stores they're gonna try something
else
smaller stores about a tenth of the size
of the current Macy's store and see if
they can put them not necessarily in a
big massive mall in normal but maybe in
a strip mall where more people seem to
be shopping and opening their wallets is
this another sign of the broader death
of traditional retail and what does it
mean for the thousands of people who
work in that industry whether it's on
the front line
or in the offices let me start with
what's gonna happen the people who work
there it's a terrible thing when these
stores closed because a lot of these
people who love being salespeople need
to find jobs these are not people who
are necessarily going to go into a
warehouse and start packing for one of
the big online retailers hopefully they
do find jobs in other sales locations
because sales the sales it's a great
skill to have so I'm hopeful that they
can move over as far as you know that's
really tough to say there were 90 300
store closures last year it's almost a
60 percent increase from the prior year
this is a trend that will accelerate
I don't think and we've seen the end of
it I'm still holding on to the mall and
losing that battle and I have a good
mall
[Laughter]